[Musique]
tous les matins à 5 heures je commence
ma deuxième vie je m'assois devant mon
ordinateur et je pars pour le xviiie
siècle
j'écris la suite des aventures du héros
que j'ai inventé augustin du rock
vétérinaire à metz au xviiie siècle et
enquêteurs de génie le plus
extraordinaire c'est qu'il invite le
lecteur à suivre cette deuxième vie en
lisant ses aventures et l'a installé
dans votre canapé
nous allons vivre avec lui nous allons
être poursuivi à cheval jeter tout
ligoté dans une mare embastillé et nous
allons avoir peur nous allons avoir
froid nous allons avoir faim nous allons
être amoureux
nous allons nous désespérer et puis
trouver en nous l'énergie de nous sortir
d'une situation difficile et diocésains
augustin du rock en traversent des
situations difficiles mais c'est le
miracle de la fiction
il s'en sort toujours il en sort
toujours et il nous donne des clés pour
nous sortir nous mêmes de nos propres
difficultés
augustin du rock vétérinaire à metz au
xviiie siècle et enquêteurs de génie
quelle drôle d'idée d'avoir campé un
vétérinaire comme enquêteur plutôt qu'un
commissaire de police
et bien il y a une raison à cela
je viens d'une famille de vétérinaire et
mon père était le dernier de la série
c'était 5 voici et il s'est désolé
qu'aucun ses cinq enfants ne reprenne le
flambeau et dont j'ai inventé ce
personnage de vétérinaire c'est lui qui
lui succède c'est lui qui lui rend
hommage
pourquoi à metz et bien j'habite à metz
et je trouve que c'est une ville
tellement merveilleuse que j'ai eu envie
d'en faire le décor de mes histoires
pourquoi au xviiie siècle je trouve
c'est une époque passionnante on voit
émerger des idées nouvelles
les philosophes les progrès le progrès
scientifique
les montgolfières et puis c'est l'époque
où naissent les vétérinaires sont les
français qui ont inventé les écoles
vétérinaires la toute première école du
monde a été fondé à lyon en 1760 2 à
quoi ressemble ce personnage et bien
c'est un jeune homme de son temps il a
23 ans il prend de l'âge au fil des
épisodes
il est habillé de ils portent l'habit à
la française la culotte bahts soit gilet
veste et dans sa pratique de vétérinaire
il a adopté la tenue de cavaliers qui
sera d'ailleurs la tenue de tous les
vétérinaires jusqu'au xxème siècle
puisque mon père qui montait dans sa
voiture était habillé encore avec cette
tenue de cavaliers e'lara je lui ai
donné le caractère de trois personnes
mon père mon arrière grand père est
aussi un peu moi mon père c'était
quelqu'un qui était non là c'est mon
arrière-grand-père quelqu'un
d'extrêmement positif ça se voit sur sa
figure d'ailleurs était toujours de
bonne humeur
c'était quelqu'un qui s'est passionné
pour beaucoup de choses pour sa
profession il a inventé des traitements
nouveaux il a fait et publications dans
des revues scientifiques
il a reçu des prix de l'académie
vétérinaire et puis il a fait beaucoup
d'autres choses il a fait de la
politique il a passé un doctorat en
histoire à l'âge de 75 ans un doctorat
en ethnologie à l'âge de 79 ans vous
voyez jamais trop tard c'est un exemple
pour moi
mon arrière-grand-père qu'on voit là
avec sa tenue de lieutenant vétérinaire
vivait à la fin du 19e siècle début du
xxème donc je ne vais pas connu
contrairement aux apparences
d'ailleurs il ne vient une anecdote à de
mes enfants lorsqu'il avait 6 ou 7 ans
m'a demandé si quand j'étais petit il y
avait des dinosaures donc mon arrière
grand père à son époque faisait encore
ses visites à cheval
c'était le taux d'ebit l'automobile et
il a noirci des pages entières de ses
meilleurs cas de médecine vétérinaire
qui ont servi de base pour camper des
situations de vétérinaires au xviiie
siècle
sachant que la médecine avait vraiment
très peu évolué entre la fin du xviiie
siècle et la fin du 19e siècle et enfin
au but ça diront que c'est un peu moi
pour certains détails
je lui ai donné la manie que j'ai de
marché tous les jours et comme moi ils
pratiquent un sport de combat
et puis comme j'ai pratiqué la médecine
libérale pendant plus de trente ans je
sais ce que c'est que d'avoir des
angoisses par rapport à un diagnostic
je sais ce que c'est que d'avoir des
difficultés relationnelles avec des
personnes un petit peu rugueuse donc
tout cela je l' ai transmis à mon
personnage alors augustin du rock nous
promène dans son époque et il nous
montre à quel point la médecine au sens
large étaient démunis
à cette époque là par exemple on ne
connaissait des antiseptiques que le
vinaigre qui revient à la mode et
l'esprit de vin qui est donc de l'alcool
la chirurgie elle était rudimentaire
on le connaissait de la chirurgie que ce
que l'on appelle maintenant la petite
chirurgie qui consistait à enlever une
petite tumeur exter paraît une plaie 1,6
et un abcès c'est à peu près tout
et augusta du rock lui dans le tome 3 de
ses aventures que voici est amené à 1,6
et sa propre cuisse pour extraire une
balle qui l'a reçu et alors il n'ya pas
d'aller saisit donc pour se donner un
peu de courage se verse un verre de
mirabel et il le bois
augustin du rock nous promène dans son
siècle et nous montre paradoxalement
qu'il y a des points communs entre notre
époque est la sienne
par exemple la presse à scandale on a vu
à quel point elle pourrait faire des
ravages durant cette campagne
présidentielle on connaît tous ces faits
qui use qui envahissent le net et on
s'imagine à tort que c'est une invention
récente
eh bien pas du tout la presse à scandale
est né au xviie siècle elle était
florissante au xviiie siècle
lorus un duroc est amené à aller à
versailles appelée par le ministre des
finances calonne vous allez me dire dans
un obscur vétérinaire de campagne ne
peut pas connaître le ministre des
finances eh bien si parce que calonne
avant d'être ministre des finances a été
un temps dans deux provinces et il a été
un temps dans des trois évêchés
c'est-à-dire à metz où il a vécu pendant
12 ans donc c'est un personnage
récurrent des aventures de bruce à
durenque
et donc il appelle ce genre amis à
versailles pour débrouiller une affaire
complexe et la augustin s'aperçoit que
la presse à scandales est en train de
détruire l'image dans le peuple
l'image car le le ministre des finances
calonne qui sera traîné dans la boue qui
sera calomnier tenter plus qu'il finira
par être démis de ses fonctions et c'est
cette même presse à scandale qui va
détruire aussi l'image de la reine marie
antoinette
alors cette presse fonctionner
officiellement avec une imprimerie
c'était très surveillé par la police et
la presse à scandale elias et des
officines clandestine qui employait des
copies et on appelait cela les nouvelles
à la main parce qu'elle est écrite à la
main c'était plus facile de déménager
des copistes qu'une imprimerie et donc
ses copines de recopier ce que des
la soeur de nouvelles aller espionner
dans la rue dans les cafés auprès de la
domesticité des grandes maisons
tout ça a été recopié sur des feuilles
on les vendait dans la rue à la cour on
les vendait en province aussi emporté
par les colporteurs
autre exemple la condition féminine
actuellement il ya des mouvements
féministes qui sont très actifs et ils
sont nés à la fin du 19e siècle
pourquoi parce qu'il ya une régression
de la condition des femmes entre le 18è
et le 19è siècle la révolution n'a pas
apporté que des bienfaits et donc au
xviiie siècle les visiteurs étrangers
qui venaient dans votre pays disait la
france c'est le pays des femmes les
femmes étaient libres d'aller et venir
dans la rue dans les lieux publics
on les voit souvent en tête de
manifestation
au cours de toutes ces révoltes de la
faim c'est révolte du pain j'en mets une
en scène dans l'argent des farines on
voit sur la place de chambre les femmes
partir à l'assaut d'une boulangerie en
raison de la cherté du pain et donc les
femmes étaient partout elle travaillait
la plupart les femmes du pape du peuple
travaille elle travaillait dans des
manufactures elle travaillait pour leur
propre compte elle pouvait être lingère
brodeuses dentellières à metz il y avait
aussi énormément de prostitution du fait
de la présence de la garnison messe
était la plus grosse place forte du
royaume et l héberger dans ses murs onze
mille soldats
et puis les femmes de la petite
bourgeoisie travailler avec leurs maris
à l'atelier elle servait la clientèle
elle donnait les ordres aux employés et
puis les femmes de la grande bourgeoisie
et de l'aristocratie pour certaines
d'entre elles avait suivi des études
poussées et elle tenait et salons et
dans ses salons elle invitait tous les
beaux esprits de l'époque qu'elle
faisait connaître qu'elle faisait se
rencontrer les philosophes les hommes de
science les écrivains les artistes et en
même temps elles ont codifié ce que l'on
a appelé l'art de la conversation à la
france
16 qui était très admiré dans les pays
européens l'art du beau langage l'art
des bonnes manières
autre exemple de points communs avec
notre époque
la défiance vis-à-vis des vaccins nous
avons la chance de bénéficier de vaccins
qui sont dosés avec précision et on se
paye le luxe de s'en méfier et bien
cette méfiance
elle est née dès le début de la
vaccination qu'on appelait alors
l'inoculation et qui n'intéressait que
la variole alors rien à voir avec nos
vaccins proposés avec précision là on
prenait une gouttelette de put sur par
exemple la pustule de monsieur k la
variole et ont déposé cette gouttelettes
de puces sur une scarification fait sur
le bras de madame qu'ils allaient
développer une réaction locale suivie
d'une immunisation mai